so I've got a segment today about energy
compensation exercise energy
compensation so this is a topic that we
are revisiting we've covered it before
uh but a couple things have changed
first of all now we have graphical
capabilities I can actually insert
images on the YouTube presentation
that'll make these things uh these
Concepts a little bit more tangible uh
and now we also have a brand new tool on
the macro Factor uh website that makes
this information a little bit more
accessible but more importantly a little
bit more actionable you know you can
actually put this stuff to use now so I
figured it was a good time to revisit
the concept and first of all someone
might be asking what is exercise energy
compensation and I think that's actually
best answered by looking at a a bit of a
problem in the research something that's
come up time and time again and to
address this problem in the research I
want to lean on
an article a mass article that the good
doctor Eric Helms wrote for mass and
it's been you know we've talked about it
before I don't like the guy but I still
appreciate his work you know and I try
to stay impartial in that regard I was
going to ask if if we'd squash the beef
but uh definitely sounds like we haven't
and that that's the way I like it if
anything it's getting it's intensifying
good you know yeah
um but you know don't like the guy but
he's done some good things I have to
give him that so his article was called
why do you flee the country and run
Halfway Around the World to New Zealand
like it it may it makes you wonder what
he's trying to get away from it does
make you wonder it makes it makes me
wonder a lot and I'm I got people
looking into it it should make more
people wonder yeah just throwing that
out there yeah and where was he when all
this fat bear week voting was going on
I don't know inquiring minds want to
know yeah so anyway his article was
called why cardio isn't as effective for
fat loss as you'd expect and that pretty
much lays out the problem people have
looked at a bunch of different uh
controlled interventions using cardio as
a fat loss tool and results have been uh
I think it's safe to say pretty
underwhelming so in this particular
article he was reviewing a paper by
Broski and colleagues which was called
effective aerobic exercise induced
weight loss on the components of daily
energy expenditure that's a great name
Broski Broski it is a good name now in
this study they had 42 participants they
were individuals with obesity and they
were put into three groups one was
basically a control group one was an
aerobic exercise group that was doing a
lower amount of total weekly exercise so
they were trying to burn eight
kilocalories per kilogram of body weight
per week so they were kind of tailoring
the exercise dose accordingly and then
there was also this higher expenditure
group who is shooting for 20
kilocalories per kilogram of weight per
week
um so they were they were doing this
intervention they were also looking at a
whole bunch of metrics pertaining to
energy expenditure so uh The Cliff Notes
I'll put up a table that shows some of
the more detailed uh results of the
intervention but the cliff notes is the
high expenditure group uh they did lose
a signific statistically significant
amount of body weight but it was only
half the amount that would be expected
mathematically if you basically crunch
the numbers and said how many calories
were they supposed to burn off with this
exercise dose it basically only
delivered about half of the
mathematically anticipated weight loss
they also found that their total daily
energy expenditure increased by about
four percent driven by by the increase
in exercise but when they brought them
into a metabolic chamber and directly
measured their energy expenditure for 24
hours
of course in that at rest right at rest
yeah so I was going to say of course in
that chamber they weren't exercising
yeah uh when they took it from free
living conditions and said okay without
the added influence of that exercise
what's your kind of just basal resting
energy expenditure like resting not
basil over this 24-hour period and it
actually decreased by four percent it
appeared that there was a kind of a
compensatory change in other
non-exercise elements of energy
expenditure uh now the lower dose group
that was doing less exercise uh their uh
body weight was not reduced to a
statistically significant uh degree so
uh basically what they concluded there
was that uh aerobic exercise at this
higher dose uh was able to produce
weight loss but it was less weight loss
than expected which appeared to be
related to some kind of compensatory
reduction in non-exercise l elements of
energy expenditure so that brings me to
a model that really is at the center of
the conversation about exercise energy
compensation so
Herman ponzer is a researcher down the
road at Duke uh and he has really
popularized this idea uh of the
constrained total energy expenditure
model and I'm going to put up a figure
that kind of demonstrates what this
model proposes but but a lot of sponsors
early work was looking at total daily
energy expenditure in different
societies with very different physical
activity levels and one of the things he
noticed was you know you know I
mentioned in the previous study by
Broski they kind of did a mathematical
Assumption of how much weight ought to
be lost and going into that model is the
or going into those calculations is the
Assumption of the additive model which
if you're watching on YouTube you'll see
it on the left side of the screen but
the idea with the additive model is very
simple it's basically if you add some
exercise to your routine and you add
maybe 200 calories per day of exercise
then your total energy expenditure will
go up by 200 calories if you add 300
calories of exercise total energy
expenditure will go up by 300 calories
right it's a very very straightforward
thing
now the constrained model which you'll
see on the right side of your screen if
you're watching on YouTube this paints a
different picture now what this
indicates is that as you increase more
and more exercise or other types of
physical activity total daily energy
expenditure will go up but at a certain
point you start to get some diminishing
returns it looks like there's some kind
of sealing effect some kind of
constraint on energy expenditure when
physical activity levels get really
really high and one of the things that
is playing into that apparent ceiling
effect is it appears to be some adaptive
changes in non-exercise components of
energy expenditure so as the model
dictates as you go as you start ramping
physical activity up and up and up and
up and get to really high levels there
will be compensatory reductions in other
you know more resting components of
energy expenditure that that basically
those adaptive changes appear to just
offset the tremendous energy cost of
this added activity and it you could
kind of take it back to evolutionary uh
mechanisms and theories about why it
might be disadvantageous for us to just
kind of scale up energy expenditure more
and more and more as we have high
activity levels you could imagine in a
in an environment in which food is
scarce and you might have increased
activity for uh for foraging Gathering
hunting whatever the case may be it
might be helpful in some cases for there
to be some constraint on how much your
energy expenditure ramps up yeah now and
and also to be clear for the people who
are are listening to this can't see the
model uh on on screen it's also like
proposed to be a pretty dose-dependent
thing right absolutely that's a good
point like if you're currently
incredibly sedentary don't exercise at
all and start you know just going for a
daily walk and burning 100 calories
through exercise that might lead to a
100 calorie increase in your total daily
energy expenditure but if you're already
very active exercising a lot burning a
thousand calories per day through
exercise and you add 10 more exercise to
where now you're burning 1100 calories
per day through exercise like you're
going from from high to even higher that
100 calorie increase in exercise since
you're already quite active will lead to
an increase in total daily energy
expenditure likely considerably smaller
than 100 calories yeah so like it the
constrained model behaves very similarly
to the additive model if you're going
from sedentary to lightly active to like
moderately active maybe but if you're
going from like moderately active to
very active or like very active to
extremely active then some more of those
adaptive mechanisms set in to where you
have reductions in or larger reductions
in in other components of total energy
expenditure correct yeah and that's a
good point and there's really two main
misconceptions that are that have picked
up a lot of steam and a lot of people uh
kind of reinforce these misconceptions
unintentionally and so they've kind of
been popularized but uh the the first
misconception is the one that you just
mentioned which is that you know a lot
of people just completely ignore the
fact that this is a dose-dependent
non-linear thing that's happening right
so like you said as you go higher and
higher into really high levels of
physical activity the compensatory
reductions and other components of
energy expenditure get increasingly
larger and larger
um so so that's the one thing the other
misconception which is probably the more
impactful one is is people seem to
indicate that the level of uh
compensation here you know the amount of
energy that's being offset by these
adaptive reductions and other
non-exercise components people seem to
reinforce the idea that the compensation
level is one hundred percent like I've
heard a lot of people
who have said you cannot increase your
total daily energy expenditure through
exercise yeah because if you increase
you know 100 calories of exercise you're
just going to decrease 100 calories of
other stuff yeah it is very important to
to note that that is absolutely not what
this model indicates if you look at how
it's depicted by the person who created
it and more importantly it's not what
the data underlying the model indicate
exactly yeah the much more important
element is that people keep spreading
this idea is if we can't just look at
actual papers that have measured this
stuff yeah and the compensation level
is simply not a hundred percent uh it is
is well below 100 but that brings us to
kind of the
the main question here in this segment
which is well what is the magnitude of
compensation and just to be super clear
when I talk about the magnitude of
compensation I'm talking about you know
to what what percentage of this increase
in exercise energy expenditure is being
offset by compensatory reductions and
other components of total daily energy
expenditure so
the magnitude of compensation if you're
asking what is it well it's not a
hundred percent
but unfortunately it turns out to be
quite variable from person to person and
from Context to context so I wish that I
could say hey it's not 100 it's 30. but
I I can't really say that uh because
it's extremely context dependent and it
does vary a lot among individuals so
there are a few key characteristics that
we can look at when we're trying to
figure out okay well for me or maybe for
my client that I'm coaching what is a
reasonable expectation for the magnitude
of compensation and and just to just to
make make all of this very explicit
because I think sometimes people get
confused when you're throwing out
percentages it's like ah percentage of
what so just to be like very very
explicit to say that
thirty percent compensation occurs
implies that if you burn 100 calories
from exercise thirty percent of those
calories won't kind of contribute to
increases in total daily energy
expenditure so 30 compensation means if
exercise increases by 100 calories total
daily energy expenditure increases by 70
calories correct so like a higher
compensation number means a smaller
increase in total daily energy
expenditure as exercise increases a
smaller compensation number means a
larger increase in total daily energy
expenditure as exercise increases
exactly so yeah for that 100 calories
worth of exercise example uh if you're
doing that 100 calories of extra
exercise and it's a 10 compensation
value your you know total daily energy
expenditure goes up by 90 calories if
it's a 50 compensation value then total
daily energy expenditure only goes up by
50 calories
um so one of the things that that a lot
of people have kind of speculated about
is does this vary based on biological
sex you know does it seem to differ a
lot when we compare males to females and
there's a paper by Caro and colleagues
um it's the best evidence available to
date to actually explore that question
and the answer appears to be no it
doesn't seem like there's kind of a
systematic bias by which compensation
levels differ when we compare males to
females for this particular outcome uh
as we've mentioned previously you know
people have asked does it differ
depending on your total activity level
absolutely so if you are someone who
like you said earlier has a very low
Baseline activity level
and you're just adding a little bit of
exercise you can anticipate a low
compensation value which means you're
getting the most bang for your buck if
you're increasing physical activity and
hoping to increase total daily energy
expenditure uh if you're someone who is
extremely active already uh then you can
expect a much larger compensation factor
which again means that the exercise that
you're adding is having a a more
constrained or restricted impact on
total daily energy expenditure so
activity level absolutely plays a big
role another thing that plays a big role
apparently seems to be energy balance so
I'm going to put an image on the screen
here this is from a paper by Willis and
colleagues but they were interested in
looking at using a big sample of
participants with really high quality
measurements they had WWE labeled water
data accessible for this particular
study they were looking at essentially
the degree of compensation and how that
varies for people who are in negative
neutral or positive energy balance so
you know neutral energy balance means
you're just eating at maintenance
basically staying pretty weight stable
negative energy balance means you're in
a caloric deficit and so over time you
could expect to be losing weight and
positive energy balance means you're in
an energy Surplus which means over a
longer time scale you could expect to
gain weight now for people who are in
neutral or positive energy balance the
additive model did just fine so again
the additive model basically assumes
minimal compensation technically it
assumes zero compensation so what what
that tells us is people in neutral and
positive energy balance the compensation
value is quite low such that the
additive model did just fine uh in terms
of of kind of uh you know predicting how
total energy expenditure would change or
what kind of compensation level we would
anticipate uh however looking
specifically at people in negative
energy balance so people who were in an
energy deficit the constrained model did
a better job explaining the data when
compared to the additive model so what
that tells us is for someone who's in
negative energy balance we can expect
that it will essentially increase the
degree to which they compensate for an
increase in exercise energy expenditure
so smaller compensation values for
people in neutral or positive energy
balance larger compensation values for
people in negative energy balance
one final consideration or
characteristic that comes up a lot in
this research is BMI
now there was a the study I mentioned
previously by Caro and colleagues uh
excellent study and a really really nice
data set that they're working with uh it
it's the doubly labeled water database
um I forget the acronym of who houses it
it's like the international
atomic energy agency or something like
that I I believe that's correct yeah but
anyway huge database there's been a lot
of great papers coming out of it lately
uh really impressive collaborative
multi-center effort which is what we
need in the research world so the reason
I keep uh kind of like gushing about it
is because it really is a a tremendous
utility for the research World
um but anyway uh this paper by Caro and
colleagues they identified that
compensation levels did seem to vary
based on BMI
and what they found was when they looked
at people at the 10th percentile of BMI
so people with low BMI values the
compensation uh value that they
calculated was around 29 30 give or take
when they looked at the 90th percentile
of BMI so higher BMI values uh the
compensation value was all the way up
around 46 percent uh so it was a
meaningful BMI related uh difference in
terms of the compensation value but
the question about BMI is really
challenging
um I'm not quite certain what to do with
it practically speaking because when we
look at an observational relationship
like this where BMI seems to be
predictive of compensation values
there are a few things that could be
going on so so for example
um
a question you might ask is you know is
high exercise energy compensation a
hereditary characteristic that
predisposes someone to developing a
higher BMI or does the development of a
higher BMI somehow increase exercise
energy compensation it's kind of a
chicken and egg scenario and an
observational study like this doesn't
really give us an opportunity to answer
that with with a high degree of
confidence
um
one possibility you know someone might
also ask is it possible that energy
compensation estimates might be to some
extent distorted by the fact that BMI
fails to distinguish between fat mass
and fat-free Mass uh which which
obviously fat free mass is far more
predictive of resting energy expenditure
uh that is possible some of these
studies try to to go in and account for
that uh statistically but it is
something that muddies the water a
little bit when we when we try to make
when we try to take that BMI information
and kind of extrapolate to body fat
percentage or something like that
um another question that I think is is
is a really important question is
is it possible that people with higher
bmis
in these studies are simply more likely
to be intentionally restricting energy
intake such that the observed effect of
BMI is actually more related to the
current state of energy balance yeah uh
to me that is a really important
potential confounder that you know when
we look at these huge sets of data is it
possible that people with higher bmis
are more likely to be doing physical
activity for the purpose of weight
reduction or or they they might be
simultaneously trying to establish an
energy deficit so it's very possible
that the BMI effect could be really just
showing us what was previously discussed
in that Willis paper which is that
higher compensation values are observed
in negative energy balance yeah it's
like the classic finding that uh the
people who consume more diet sodas tend
to have higher bmis but it's like yeah
the the diet sodas aren't causing that
like they're go they're going out of
their way to drink diet soda because
they're trying to lose weight yeah yeah
so so I presented some questions here
that are worth consideration that I
simply don't have the answers to
um but the ones I presented so far are
are kind of uh specific here's a vague
one that is still applicable it's still
a very valid question which is could
there simply be other behavioral
characteristics that just distinguish
individuals with low bmis from
individuals with higher bmis such that
the observed effect of BMI is driven by
something else entirely with this type
of observational approach so far like I
said it's the best data that we
currently have but there are inherently
limitations to the types of conclusions
we can draw so when it comes to the BMI
effect I'm simply not that certain about
what to do with it it's something that
I'm monitoring really closely whenever a
new study comes out I got my hopes up
this past month there was a study that
came out that looked like maybe it would
it would provide some additional Insight
but unfortunately it just didn't get at
the question the way I was hoping it
would and so for now uh the BMI
relationship exists it's something
that's out there but in terms of
practical application it's it's one that
we simply don't know what to do with but
what we can say with a decent amount of
certainty so far based on the evidence
is that the degree of compensation
doesn't appear to be dictated by
biological sex definitely seems to
depend on activity level and does seem
to be related to current the
individual's current state of energy
balance I can I can tell you what my
hunch is for the BMI thing as someone
who does uh certainly have plenty of
experience with uh with both being fat
and just being very different sizes
throughout my life
um I mean I I think that that first
thing you you threw out is high exercise
energy compensation a hereditary
characteristic or does the development
of obesity somehow increase compensation
I suspect it's probably both
um like that that's like I certainly
have uh hereditary factors working
against me
um and even when even when like I I am
or have been smaller like uh a thing
that people tell me is like oh man like
I can go for a jog in the morning and
like I feel great that just energizes me
for the rest of the day and whenever
someone says that to me I'm like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
um you know I'm not denying their
experience but I can tell you good and
well I have never had that experience in
my life uh if I do any exercise
whatsoever even if I'm already in good
shape it it doesn't have an energizing
effect like I just I just want to chill
the rest of the day
um or or at least chill more than I
otherwise would have but then also the
impact of that is also influenced by how
large I am at the time like when I am
smaller uh exercise just doesn't take it
out of me as much the same way
um so yeah like I think that there that
that is always just kind of like a
factor in the background based on just
some hereditary characteristics I'm
dealing with
um but I also think that that for for me
personally like my exercise energy
compensation is a lot higher when when
I'm heavier than when I'm not yeah
that's an interesting observation and
there
you know
we follow the research more closely than
the typical person
um because every month we're going
through the journal Sweep with hundreds
of studies and just keeping an eye on
what people are doing I would say that
this particular question is on my very
short list of of research questions that
I'm eagerly trying to chase down
um I I really hope that people will get
at this from creative ways you know like
take really creative approaches I I
think one thing that comes to mind is
like it would be interesting to expand
upon your anecdote with even just some
qualitative research uh getting groups
of people with very different body sizes
and weight histories and just saying
what is your experience with exercise
you know like I mean how does it impact
your energy level the rest of that day
that week how does it impact appetite
responses like I do think that that's a
really valuable uh it's it's an a
valuable opportunity where quality
research could really help dictate how
to get at it in the future
experimentally yeah um and I I'd like to
just broadly see more qualitative
research in our field I think
I know that uh James Steele's group has
done a few qualitative studies recently
um and I that that's a trend that I very
much like I hope that people will will
carry that forward Israel Halperin and
his and his collaborators they they do
some qualitative work too right yeah
yeah it's it's a lot of people
um when they see a qualitative study
they kind of have a double take if
they're not used to that whole world of
research but but it can really help fill
in gaps and and guide a lot of
hypothesis generation for sure yeah and
I mean if we just ignore qualitative
research there there is a
just large a breadth of human experience
that is difficult to quantify and like
Newtons or inches or kilograms or
whatever
um that yeah like if if we don't have
quality like if if we don't have
qualitative research or just like ignore
the qualitative research we're
essentially closing ourselves off from
like a pretty large proportion of the
total questions that could be asked in
tentatively answered by research yeah
for sure uh so moving on we've talked
about all this exercise energy
compensation stuff it seems interesting
um but it's kind of hard to put that
into action you know um you you have to
do a lot of calculations and kind of
make a lot of estimates about what this
value should be and that value should be
so that is why we developed a tool to
help with this so I'll link it in the
show notes if you go to
macrofactorapp.com
exercise calorie calculator with a
hyphen between uh all those those three
words there it'll take you to a
calculator that estimates the net impact
of a specific exercise bout on your
total daily energy expenditure so it
will be customized to your body size the
modality of exercise the duration of and
the intensity of exercise and we will
also uh basically do a a prediction of
your compensation value based on the
characteristics that We Gather in this
tool so we ask you kind of a short
series of questions use that information
to determine things like your most
likely resting energy expenditure your
most likely compensation value
um you know we we get the
characteristics of the exercise bout
and for the exercise bout uh what what
we do is we we pull met values from the
2011 compendium of physical activity by
Ainsworth and colleagues
um so that full compendium uh has like
over 800 types of exercise so I think if
people check out this tool they're going
to be very surprised to see the variety
of exercise modalities and intensities
uh that are represented within this tool
so you previously
um I I had made a little spreadsheet
available I didn't really talk about it
much but I made a little spreadsheet and
it was like well you have to go find the
net value of your exercise and you have
to go tell me what you think your
compensation value is and stuff like
that it just wasn't very user friendly
which is why I didn't talk about it much
it was like Hey this exists but there's
a lot of footwork that you have to do
yourself yeah
um in this instance you just click the
link answer some really basic questions
about yourself and uh and it helps you
out so
obviously people are going to be
critical and say oh you're just trying
to you know push this thing it's totally
free
You couldn't possibly make us any richer
by using this so this isn't like a big
advertisement this is just an area of
research I've been following closely and
we're pretty stoked to be able to put
together a tool that that we think is
pretty helpful here yeah because I mean
like this is I mean
this concept isn't totally novel like
there there are like exercise
calculators out there that you can find
um but the the I haven't seen another
one that gives any sort of guidance
about what amount of compensation you
should expect so they they kind of they
seem to tacitly operate on the additive
model or just kind of like
hope that you know what to do with it
like if you uh like go on a run and it
says like oh yeah you probably burn like
350 calories on that run
and it's like well what should you do
with it like how much should that impact
your dietary targets how much is that
likely to impact your total daily energy
expenditure yeah who knows like you
could look through the research for
yourself and like try to make some
estimates but this calculator is novel
in the sense that like it it does all of
that leg work for you based on based on
the research that we have and what we do
currently know about energy compensation
um instead of just kind of spitting out
how many calories it expects you have
burned in the training session itself or
the exercise session itself it estimates
what that likely net impact is on your
total daily energy expenditure and the
thing I love about it the most is it
actually gives like a probable range for
where those
Those comp for like where those
compensation values might fall
we need ranges on a lot more things in
this world folks uh especially if you're
if you're predicting something or
estimating something
um like I understand why people do this
and I'm not I'm not faulting anyone for
it like it's it's a lot easier for any
sort of just like web app or whatever to
just like do some math and spit out a
single number that looks like a very
precise Point estimate
um and it's a lot harder to kind of like
deal with the logic on the back end to
like present things as a range in the
first place uh so I I don't think
anyone's trying to be like dishonest uh
or trying to mislead people but I do
think a lot of just online calculators
that exist for all sorts of things do
give people uh sometimes like an
excessive
um illusion of precision about the
calculations they're doing where if
something says like dude you're burning
437.6 calories you're like holy [ __ ]
like if you got that decimal in there
man it it must be that or something
extremely extremely close to it but no I
mean anything like this
um
it's a it's an estimate like it's an
approximation at best so any any
estimate there is like
an inherent implied range of variability
around that point estimate uh and this
calculator actually makes it explicit
which uh I think is very nice yeah I
think you know like you said there are
other exercise energy expenditure
calculators that exist
um but but they basically have three
three things that I would view as
shortcomings or maybe we're just doing a
different thing than what they're doing
but uh like you said they don't reflect
the level of precision very well
um they they just give you a single
number they don't really give you a
range to help you understand okay I know
this isn't exact but what what's the
realistic probable range we're talking
about here so that's one shortcoming
another thing is that they they don't
frame it relative to your predicted
resting energy expenditure and the
reason that matters is because if you
were not exercising you would still
exist
um so so the question is not how many
calories did I burn during that session
but how many more did I burn versus an
alternate reality where I was just
hanging out sitting around you know so
so the added component is important
there
um and then another element like you
said is they don't take any effort to
deal with the the concept of energy
compensation which again as we've talked
about it's not a hundred percent but
it's certainly not zero percent in the
vast majority of cases either
um so yeah I think people listening
might say okay that sounds good
it sounds like you've improved upon an
idea that previously existed but you
might be wondering why this would
actually be useful
um aside from just being interesting so
there's three use cases that come to
mind for me uh the first one most
straightforward based on some of the
research we've talked about previously
this calculator makes it easier to
incorporate exercise changes into a
weight loss program or a weight gain
program but basically it helps you say
okay I'm changing up my exercise how
might I change up my nutrition in order
to accommodate that while I'm pursuing
some kind of weight related goal whether
it's weight loss weight gain weight
maintenance
um so so this uh helps you make since it
is focusing on the net impact on total
daily energy expenditure it's a much
more tangible way to make those kinds of
decisions about how you can adjust your
diet to accommodate these exercise
changes
um a second potential use case maybe
you're just cruising toward whatever
body composition goal that you have in
mind but there's some atypical exercise
ballot that pops up right so like maybe
you're gonna do uh like a charity run or
you're gonna accompany a friend on like
a pretty tough hike
um and you're like okay I want to
account for that with with my dietary
intake you know I like the rate of
weight change I'm experiencing and I
just want to keep it going so I want to
make sure I'm I'm accommodating this
unexpected increase in expenditure now
of course
a one-off exercise bout like this is not
going to derail your long-term efforts
whether you're trying to gain lose
maintain weight uh but some people
simply want to uh some people just feel
better about saying okay I I feel like
I'm taking some proactive step to kind
of steady the ship here and keep my
energy availability relatively constant
rather than having this huge variation
where where this one day I'm in an
unusually large deficit right so that
that's a very justifiable uh use case
for this another one would be
um you know maybe you're gearing up for
an anticipated change in your exercise
habits and you just want to be proactive
about ensuring that you're actually
fueling those efforts you know so maybe
you're really kicking up your training a
notch or you know maybe you're going to
do like a charity run and you're going
to start a training program for it and
you're like I just want to make sure
that I am fueling those workouts
effectively and that as I ramp up my
physical activity here that I'm going to
be you know adequately fueled for
workouts and adequately recovering from
them as well you want to make sure that
you're not under eating relative to your
change in exercise and so so this gives
you a tool that helps you do that in a
way that's really personalized and you
know these predictive equations like I
said are going to be completely tailored
to your situation which is very
different from just relying on some
heuristic that says oh yeah running
generally Burns about this many calories
or something like that so um
what I'm going to do is on the screen on
YouTube if I can figure out the
technology I'm going to actually show an
example here uh so basically you can go
into this tool and it's going to ask you
to select a type of exercise right and
so for this example I'm going to put in
uh cycling as the prompt here and I'm
going to scroll down and find a
Stationary bicycling and I'm going to do
that at 90 to 100 Watts so maybe I've
got like one of those uh you know
stationary bikes that shows me my
wattage on the screen as I'm pedaling
and I'm planning to be 90 100 Watts but
of course if you open up the tool and
look at the the different exercises
available there is a huge variety it's
not like everything is going to make you
calculate a watt value some of it is
very very real world in terms of how it
describes the exercise some of it is
more quantitative like this particular
selection so you're going to choose the
exercise type and confirm it then you're
going to type in the duration in minutes
so we're going to say 30 30 minutes of
cycling in this 90 to 100 watt range
you're going to put in your body weight
for this example we'll say 70 kilograms
that's kind of the the most generic body
weight you'll ever find in the research
it's always a 70 kilogram person uh body
fat percentage let's say 15 but as you
can see hopefully on the screen the tool
does provide some um some visuals to
kind of help you
broadly assess where your body fat
percentage might be and this doesn't
have to be exact you just have to get
within a you know within hopefully a few
percentage points either way it doesn't
have to be precise just want to get in
the ballpark there close only counts for
horseshoes hand grenades and also this
uh this exercise energy expenditure
calculator absolutely as the as the
popular saying goes absolutely and then
now uh what we're going to do is uh
indicate whether we're gaining losing or
maintaining weight currently because
like we said previously uh you know
current energy status can be a pretty
important factor so for this example I'm
going to say I'm maintaining weight so
I'm in neutral energy balance relatively
speaking it's going to ask how many
training sessions I I typically do per
week
um and this isn't specific necessarily
to this exercise bout it's just your
general training habits overall so I'm
going to say I train one to three
training sessions per week throughout a
typical week and it's also going to ask
me about my general Act activity level
so for this example let's say that I
walk somewhere between five thousand to
fifteen thousand steps per day that
would put me in the moderate activity
level category so I'm going to select
that and if you don't know how many
steps per day you take that's totally
fine those are just to kind of help
people get kind of get a general Vibe of
how these categories work but but you
basically can make your own assessment
about generally speaking outside of the
gym outside of structured exercise uh
your your non-exercise activity level
day-to-day are you typically pretty
sedentary pretty active or kind of
moderate or somewhere in the middle so
you're going to type in those things
pretty simple pretty easy to use and
it's going to tell me that
my added energy expenditure from
exercise after accounting for
compensation is 136 kilocalories but the
probable range is somewhere in the
ballpark of 78 to 194 calories so uh
this is how the tool works again this is
trying to assess the net impact on total
daily energy expenditure which can be
very very informative for the variety of
use cases that I mentioned the last
thing I want to mention though here is
there is one use case that I would very
strongly in no uncertain terms
discourage there's one way that I really
don't want to see people using this tool
I have no way of knowing if anyone uses
it for this but I would really
discourage people from using this tool
for one specific thing so Halloween is
coming up in the United States oh yeah
uh it is a candy driven holiday and
Thanksgiving is coming up as well
believe it or not it kind of snuck up
this year as it does all years but
within the next six six weeks we're
gonna have two very food focused
holidays uh in the United States and a
lot of well-intentioned Fitness
enthusiasts and fitness professionals
and influencers on the internet are
going to talk a little bit about yeah
they're going to post about how
oh if you have two fun-sized KitKat bars
here's how many miles you have to walk
to offset that or here's how many
minutes of circuit training you have to
do to burn off those calories how many
licks does it take to get to the center
of a Tootsie Pop I have no idea but
here's how many jumping jacks you would
need to do to make up for it exactly so
so that is a genre of Fitness content
that is going to hit the internet pretty
hard uh over the next six weeks or so
um and people are going to start kind of
reinforcing this idea of making these
transactional deals where you're trading
exercise in order to afford some kind of
food you know whether it's you know
mashed potatoes on Thanksgiving or a fun
size Reese's cup on on Halloween so
people are going to be reinforcing this
idea that you have to earn calories or
that you have to trade exercise in order
to justify eating calories uh that is
completely antithetical to everything
that that we believe about eating and
exercise it reinforces some really
problematic perspectives about food and
exercise it uh is based on the
literature pertaining to the psychology
that goes into eating behaviors it's
just bad news in every possible sense
okay so we absolutely don't enforce that
we we don't uh support or reinforce that
kind of perspective about the
relationship between food and exercise
if you want a candy bar eat a damn candy
bar you know there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that you don't have to
justify it you don't have to you know
cross off some list and say yeah I did
146 jumping jacks or whatever
calculation you find uh we we want to
completely
separate ourselves from that perspective
and I would really discourage using this
particular tool to try to do any kind of
transactional bargaining where you say
okay
I've decided that you know tonight I'm
going to have this 300 calorie kind of
hedonic deviation so let me go and kind
of mess around with this calorie
calculator and see what I got to do to
make up for that I I just would strongly
discourage people from doing that
because that's no way to live and based
on the research it's also no way to view
food or exercise yeah it's a radical
perspective but it's fine to simply
enjoy things right I think that uh I
think that like the the Protestant
um like the Puritan ethos is just like
deeply infected the American mind
um like to an extent where like it
applies to even people who wouldn't
consider themselves like particularly
puritanical where there's this idea I
think some people have where if you if
you enjoy something too much like if
something's too good
it's got to be bad right in some way
like it has to be perhaps sinful uh in
like the original conception and so you
either need to have like guilt or shame
attached to it or you need to like
self-flagellate and do some sort of
penance like in this case like X number
of sit-off sit-ups to like burn off that
uh that Hershey's bar or whatever
um
and like yeah like you just don't have
to it's it's fine to just enjoy things
have a good time
um and especially since their holidays I
mean Halloween comes around once a year
Thanksgiving comes around once a year
um it is it would be virtually
impossible to do so much damage on those
days that it uh significantly derails
you from whatever goals you're pursuing
the other
363 days out of the year so yeah yeah
it's fine like just just have fun enjoy
yourself
um don't don't come to this calculator
on November 1st and try to figure out
what what you got to do to pay off the
debt yeah I mean you know
mathematical estimates of the energy
cost of storing a new kilogram of fat
you know somewhere in the ballpark of 9
400 kilocalories so yeah doing the
calculus for the fun size KitKat bar is
psychologically not ideal and
physiologically Irrelevant in the long
run for your body composition goals and
one more thing uh one of the one of the
very fun things about macro factor that
that I think is super cool is the
Thanksgiving thing so oh yeah with AI
described within it you can you can kind
of speak into the phone microphone and
kind of report your food that way and uh
you you can basically just say like is
it Thanksgiving or is it Thanksgiving
dinner
um it is Thanksgiving dinner yeah so if
you just say Thanksgiving dinner it'll
actually give you like a pretty
representative meal for Thanksgiving
dinner that you can log so that way you
can be like okay like
um generally you know keeping my finger
on the pulse here but I'm having a low
stress enjoyable food-centered holiday
that doesn't have any you know any uh
guilt or shame associated with it and
you don't have to walk around and say
hey Grandma um can I weigh the the
cranberry sauce when you're not using it
yeah it's it's a recipe that we that we
get from the uh nutrition X Library
composed of uh several of their common
food entries six ounces of turkey a cup
of mashed potatoes with gravy half a cup
of stuffing half a cup of sweet potato
casserole half a cup of green bean
casserole quarter cup of cranberry sauce
a dinner roll teaspoon of butter and a
slice of pumpkin pie that's like what
what goes into just like the general uh
uh entry here for Thanksgiving dinner
it's like 700 or 1760 calories which I
don't know that that feel that feels
about right
um and yeah if you eat a little more
than that a little less than that if
there's uh some degree of tracking error
even like a reasonably significant
degree of tracking error for just like
one meal one day a year like ah just
just relax it's fine like that's that's
not gonna throw anything off yeah